liebe künstlerinnen und künstler die ihr
selbst auf der bühne steht ich habe nach
vielen jahren endlich herausgefunden wie
ich es schaffe gleichzeitig mir die
choreographie zu merken den text wo an
welcher stelle ich mich auf zu halten
habe auf der bühne und das kann ich nur
dann wenn ich nicht gleichzeitig was
lese also was nicht geht ist ins
publikum gucken irgend ein schild lesen
und dann seinen text rausgeben da ist
mein speicher immer völlig überlastet
also merkt euch das nicht gleichzeitig
was reden und mit dem gehirn was lesen
das geht nicht und ich habe so lange
gebraucht bis ich das endlich
herausgefunden haben dabei geht es doch
so einfach